do you watch stand-up comedy my favorite
show is Westworld obviously hahaha
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Whitney Cummings and
this is my robot bear claw what's up
bitches bear claw is new to stand up so
that's why she's sitting down with these
comics for advice do you know any female
comedians I like the way you talk
Thanks do you know any female comedians
ask me another question
oh do you know any female comedians
maybe I'm in one of those days maybe I'm
having one of those days
[Music]
Dumon my final illinois is on its own
okay like the right time yeah you have
to be just like a little cute silly
funny otherwise guys don't want to feel
like you're competing with them or they
have to compete with you what's the
worst experience you've had as a woman
in comedy easy I went in and asked if I
can get a spot and a host told me that
he can put me up because another female
convenien was there and she was prettier
than me and she had prior occasion I was
there I guess the worst experience in
that doing comedy is just not being
respected um
just off my own merits I went to a
meeting at 4:00 with a television
network in the meeting he leaned in for
a kiss yeah
and I just remember I was like what I
was in so much shock I threw my arms up
I was like no I was just I felt like
such a betrayal I thought they thought I
was funny yeah work with me it's like
that I'm sorry I don't have a specific
incident I just get a lot of
microaggressions like every show I do
there's gonna be someone before I start
my comedy they're gonna start giggling
before I say anything and it's like oh
you don't think I'm gonna be funny are
there any
topics that are off-limits or that
aren't funny absolutely not
yeah you talk about any topic it just
depends on how you talk about it yeah
comedy to me stand-up the art of it is
dying because people can't be honest
yeah if you look at Eddie Murphy's
special you look at any of the great
specials they set things that were so
disrespectful it would not be able to
stand up right now and I feel like when
people press those buttons and they
speak their honest truth that's when we
can really have these conversations that
are hard to have because comedy is used
in that space that's why it's there is
PC culture ruining comedy I think it
improves comedy because they put new
obstacles in front of you it offends me
as a trans person when people say you
can't make trans jokes this is like what
am I left out of every single room but
you can't make fun of me
Mosley's you to do comedy before you
transition now that I'm out if I say
something like that's really bad then I
make the entire trans community look bad
so it's a lot more pressure can I wear
makeup on stage yeah yeah but that being
said I do find it whenever I show up to
the comedy store to do my set after like
I had like an event or something you
know hair makeup done cute dress my sets
don't go well because everyone's sliding
heavy chairs oh my gosh yeah I do I feel
like women are intimidated and men are
just looking at our booths and so
they're not listening to us well I have
to wear makeup before my sets if I don't
then none of my jokes about being
transgender make any sense all right how
do I avoid
the end stage is annoying offstage do I
make you laugh you make me the happiest
girl in the world and yes sometimes you
make me laugh being honest I'm realizing
that my robots not a fan and it's
starting to hurt my feelings
who is your favorite comedian mr. bean I
think he's very very funny mr. bean do
you think women are funny sometimes
that's a good answer I am about to kick
my own robots ass this is really this is
really pissing me off
[Music]